hey let's go brother welcome to five
weird stuff that I found the line hello
hello Harry
oh hello look who decided to join us
kiss me again on camera I dare you
we have the best show ever today brother
I have such great items you don't even
know the first item I bought because my
friend Jack he's Irish he always speaks
in a funny accent and he's always drunk
cuz he's Irish so I want to be just like
him I bought this instant Irish spray no
way instant Irish accent my offspring
radically changes the way you speak Wow
just one quick spritz activate invisible
language receptors in your mouth holy
[ __ ] I don't know I have admissible
language receptors am I gonna spray like
acid into my mouth that will somehow
make me like that for the morning to you
laddies I'm scared my name is
jacksepticeye and welcome is that how he
does it okay ten out of ten Irishmen
the next item is zip Boom Bang you
brother suggested this one Wow Wow let's
try this bad boy out
I'm so excited what's gonna happen
[ __ ] did that mean to do that
oh it has lots of different samples the
machine gun baby bomb great fun for the
whole family
Wow the next item came today and it's
also suggested by you bros I have a lot
of it it's a pack of 24 [ __ ] drinks
let's see if they actually taste like
[ __ ] I wouldn't know it just smelled
quite like I love me some [ __ ] drink
matcha would you like some [ __ ] juice
that's good
nice nice okay now we're talking but say
I need your help on this one I think
this one goes here
oh my god this is pretty badass you know
where this is from yeah this is from a
teddy bear Naruto you watch it it's
Tokyo ghoul you watched it yes how does
it work
for the final item of today are you
excited say yes
it's a giant inflatable t-rex let's blow
this [ __ ] up oh my god Jesus Christ
yeah that was worth it